[Music]
[Music]
so what am i like asgardian or something
dude am i related to thor oh no i didn't
say any of that bruno maybe
[Music]
does this look like some kind of writing
it's hard to read um
looks like arabic or
urdu i don't know
okay
well let's focus on what we know
light comes out of you and it
hardens let's call it hard light ground
breaking
[Music]
okay so first off i just want to say
i get it
you get what
high school
kamala kamala another adventure shirt
cute she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo
you were a weirdo boys excuse me yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry
but you're staring out the window in
your little fantasy land
[Applause]
kamala hey all ready really come on like
do i have to figure out my whole future
before launchers it's like
[Music]
maybe they're right
i spend too much time
and fantasyland
that is not to you
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you save the world
that's a fantasy too
did something happen to you no why did
you hear something come on
what does it feel like
cosmic
[Music]
i always thought i wanted this kind of
life
but i never imagined any of this
do you know what you are
i'm a superhero
[Music]
so
[Music]
you